Lalo Salamanca came up to the north
after his uncle Hector suffered from a
stroke which left him paralyzed and in
need of someone to take care of the
business though a relatively small
character and a very late introduction
Lalo has dominated every scene he's been
in with his mischievous yet ingenious
character he really is Gus's main threat
as Lalo's not only just as smart but
also quite charming
which makes it easy for him to
manipulate situations and people but
really who even is Lalo
well starting off the first question
that arises is whether or not Lalo is
even a real Salamanca many rumors
suggest that Lalo simply started off as
a mercenary who worked his way up in the
hierarchy and eventually became an
honorary Salamanca
however there's really no proof of this
within the show itself at least not up
until the end of season five so for the
purposes of this video we'll just say
Lalo is indeed a real Salamanca taking a
step back and looking at the entire
family tree the person up at the top is
good old Abuelita it seems like she had
four children three of which are unknown
and one being Hector we don't know who
Hector's son or daughter is but we do
know that Tuco Lalo and Marco and Lea
know are part of this generation as we
know that they're all cousins and
nephews affector finally though we don't
know who Hector's offspring is we do
know his grandson is Joaquin as Coase
reveals at the last Salamanca aside from
Hector was his grandson Joaquin and that
he was killed as well
even though we don't know who the
missing members of the family tree are
it's likely that they were also involved
in a cartel as their sons are involved
as well plus Hector often expresses
entitlement as he believes his family is
the sole reason for the cartels success
as he declares a cartel is Salamanca
money Salamanca blooded so it's likely
that all of these members were killed
while building up the cartel considering
this it seems like the Salamanca's took
care of all the dirty work while hewan
bolsa and Don Eladio simply handled
diplomatic relationships and business
dealings with Colombians and such
furthermore we know that Marco lino and
Lalo live south of the border while
Hector and puku live in Albuquerque as a
result it's likely at a hectare and
Tuco's father were in charge of
receiving and distributing the product
in the north
meanwhile the cousins father as well as
Lala's father were in charge of picking
up the prior from the Colombians loading
up the trucks and sending it up north
and as Salamanca has died off their sons
took over the role in the operation this
means that the Salamanca
were taking on the bulk of the risk
three effectors brothers were killed
running the cartel no wonder Hector
feels like he owns the cartel anyways
with all of this information we can
conclude that Lalo and the cousins are
in charge of distribution in the south
as for how long Lalo has been in the
business in the Donal audio video we
figured out that the cartel was slightly
started in around 1980 we know that
Hector's grandson Joaquin was an adult
himself likely in his late 20s or early
30s even with the generational gap of
just 20 years this means that Lalo would
have been in his late 40s or early 50s
if he was alive when Gus took revenge on
the cartel this means that he was 40 to
45 years old during the early 2000s
better call Saul days this also means
that he was already an adult aged 18 to
22 or on the time the cartel was started
so he was likely involved from the start
of the cartel and has spent his entire
adult life working for the cartel
starting off by assisting his father and
eventually taking over distribution in
the south along with his cousins after
his death so that's roughly Lalo's
history as well as his role within the
cartel but given his deep servitude
within the organization this brings up
the classic question how much money did
Louis all among can make well to answer
that we have to first take a look at how
the Salamanca's handled their money
though a lot of the Salamanca's are
psychotic and respite for one thing the
value above everything else is family
and respect and so it's likely that they
believe that the money each member makes
is a family's money as opposed to each
individual share looking at the huge
vault of money in season 5 episode 8 it
seems that the Salamanca simply store
all their money in such places and
withdraw from there whenever Salamanca
needs it so to ask to meet Lalo sure we
simply have to take a look at the total
money the Salamanca family has made and
divided by the number of living
Salamanca's to figure out the Salamanca
share out of a total revenue we'll take
a look at the ratios we establish and
how much does Gus fring make video in
that video we establish at the cartel
gets 30 percent mules get 20 percent
dealers get 20 percent right
men like Mike tires and Victor get 10%
and finally Gus gets 20% now a lot of
you guys commented that Gus doesn't use
mules as he built up his own
distribution network to clarify what I
meant by mules in that video are the
people working in Gus's distribution
network like the guy is driving the Lost
Boys hermanos trucks and packing up a
part just because he built up his own
network doesn't mean that it's free
however it is likely that he has more
control over them and that it's cheaper
but we stuck with the 20% mule price in
that video to keep Gus's earnings
conservative applying the same ratio
Salamanca's business the same 30% would
go to a cartel or basically Don Eladio
and the manufacturers ask for mules the
Salamanca's don't need as many mules ask
us because they don't do dead drops Gus
needs mules to transport to the north
and mules to distribute it to dealers in
the North the Salamanca's however
straight-up deal with the dealers in the
ice cream shop so they only need the
mules that transport up to north as a
result we'll assume this cost a
Salamanca's half away would cost Gus at
10% the dealers would get the same 20%
and right-hand men like nacho and all
the ones in Mexico would also likely get
the same 10% so the Salamanca's or
roughly left with 30% of the total
revenue the calculated or revenue will
use the numbers that were determined in
the Donal audio video if you guys are
interested in how exactly these numbers
were determined then make sure check out
the video but essentially we analyze how
many packages of cocaine Gus was
shipping and how much money he was able
to give Don Eladio to approximate the
total revenue each month gus was able to
give Don Eladio 1.8 million per month
using 12 package shipments so with the
Salamanca's likely 5 package shipments
which we determined based on how much
Gus saw Hector should get they were able
to pull in approximately 750,000 dollars
per month for Don Eladio we already
termined that Don Eladio sure as well as
the Salamanca sure are both 30% so
750,000 is how much is a Lamont castle
roughly profiting per month up until May
2004 which is were season 5 better call
Saul ends
between 1980 and 2004 this adds up to a
total of 216 million dollars after this
the Salamanca business basically falls
apart because nacho runs away Lala has
to lay low in Mexico and Tuco is in jail
eventually Tuco does take over the
business
up north dealing with Matt but that
didn't last very long plus toca was very
impressed with Walter being able to
produce just four pounds per week so I
don't think he was dealing very much
anyways even assuming that Tuco moved 5
pounds per week of street grade math at
1,700 pounds and assuming that to co2
control right after law left in mid-2004
all the way up to his death in late 2008
the Salamanca's 30% cut would only be
9.5 million and that's with the
best-case scenario
it's likely that Tuco was actually in
jail for a few years after Lalo left and
that they weren't pulling in any revenue
for a bit of time so if anything that's
all Amon has profited a couple million
during that time pulling up to a total
profit to about 220 million in the drug
business subtracting 20 million for any
issues the Salamanca's made
approximately 200 million assuming that
the six family members that we know of
or the only ones that are still alive
Lalo would be worth about 33 million or
conservatively 25 to 30 million
we know bail cost 7 million but this
likely didn't come out of his share of
the money as I said before the
Salamanca's likely shared their money
and his bill money came from everyone
share as Lalo went to north to save the
failing business he porque familia as
todo but that is what I think what do
you guys think about Lalo make sure to
comment that down below also if you guys
like this analysis they measured up a
like and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one